well I know I know another tears the
kingdom is Awesome video right it's the
last thing we needed well what if you
did not enjoy the Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild now look I'm not gonna waste
your time trying to lead you on if you
just outright hated or strongly disliked
breath of the wild and tears the kingdom
probably not gonna do anything for you
however if you like me were just
lukewarm on breath of the wild maybe you
enjoyed it or you found some elements
that you liked but you didn't understand
why I was getting all these tens and why
some people were calling it their
favorite game ever made I was honestly
pretty skeptical on tears of the Kingdom
going in I mean it just seems like a few
very short weeks ago that I made a video
saying exactly why I didn't get the hype
now the game is out and truly you guys
it is all I can think about right now
basically I'm either playing tears of
the Kingdom thinking about playing tears
of the Kingdom or editing videos for
this YouTube channel one of those three
things is what I am doing right now with
my time so what is it about this game
that has won me over so much more and
I've been racking my brain the past few
days and I think I've narrowed it down
to three things and it all starts with
the abilities the abilities in this game
you guys are absolutely insane and and
when I say insane it's like they're so
simple at their core and yet they just
work 95 of the time there are sometimes
where things get a little weird I've
heard a lot of people saying it always
works no it does not always work I've
already had two not really game breaking
bugs but there was this one moment where
I got stuck underneath a raft and there
was no way for me to get out I couldn't
use any abilities all I had to do was
swim until my stamina depleted and died
and it basically let me restart but 95
of the time I would say all of this just
works and it works so beautifully and I
wasn't even one of those people who
loved this whole rafting system that
they had going on in breath of the wild
and here it all comes together so much
better because of the abilities I've
heard some people say and it always
sounds so cliche when they do is that
this makes breath of the wild feel like
the 0.5 or like it was a beta test for
this game and after playing this now man
I I see why people would say that
because this one just feels
sell more polished so much more put
together this feels like the game that
they were trying to make back then and I
really think it all starts with these
abilities so let's talk about fuse When
anybody pops into my stream and says hey
I didn't love the weapons breaking down
in breath of the wild I'm like guess
what I didn't either this time though
fuse quite literally changes the game it
changes this whole mechanic I'm one of
those people who wants to get the two to
three weapons that I really enjoy using
and just stick with it and I think
that's part of the reason that breath of
the wild frustrated me a lot is because
I would find something I like and then
you just have to count down the time
Until It Breaks and so I kept thinking
why do I not feel this way about tears
of the kingdom and it's all because of
the fuse mechanic I am constantly
encouraged to take these just wide range
of materials that they've given you in
this game to fuse new weapons and this
is one of those areas I don't even want
to look at guides I don't even want to
know what the best crafting things are I
I do not want to know because it
encourages the experimentation with me
so now when a weapon breaks kind of
strange because I almost get a little
excited because it opens up a slot and
now I get to experiment with some new
weapon maybe I'm gonna be able to find
something even bigger better or
something even crazier so if you had a
problem with that in breath of the wild
I do think fuse goes a long way to
helping not fully remedy it because it's
not completely gone I mean it is still
there so if you just outright hate it
who knows how I'm gonna be feeling if I
do find a few weapons that I really
really love to fuse together and then I
can never find the materials again but
right now I'm just having so much fun
with that experimentation all right
Ascend we gotta talk about Ascend next
so Ascend is the ability that I keep
forgetting to use if you've been
following games for a long time you've
almost certainly seen one of those
Infamous glitches where you glitch quite
literally through the world so your
character can move through areas that
they're not supposed to be able to move
through a lot of speedrunners actually
use tactics like this to Traverse from
one area really far away to a completely
different spot that you're probably not
supposed to be able to do I love how
tears of the Kingdom basically takes
that idea and says you know what we're
gonna take the bug and we're going to
turn it into a feature we're gonna add
it as a feature an ability that they
want you to use where you can quite
literally pass through an enormous
mountain or a simple platform as long as
it's above you and as long as it's kind
of a smooth surface you wouldn't think
something like this would be such a game
changer but it absolutely is so much so
that I'm having to retrain my brain to
actually use this there was a moment the
other day where I had this Little Rock
above me and I was looking all around
trying to think okay what can I build to
get up here and then someone in my chat
just popped in and said uh ascend
and it just again it's so simple and yet
for traversal it is incredible and I'm
only scratching the surface I mean I'm
still very early in the game right now
and then I touched on Ultra hand a bit
there Ultra hand I'll be totally honest
with you guys going in I was skeptical
of ultra hand I am not one of those
people who loves tinkering in games I'm
not I don't want to build all these
creations that right there is all my son
my nine-year-old son absolutely loves
the tinkering the crafting the building
in games he plays so much fortnite and
he just spends hours in Creative
building his own Maps so this is the
mechanic when they showed it off again
it was one of those things where I just
sort of felt uneasy I don't think I'm
really gonna get into this and yet now
that the game is here
totally into it guys I'm really trying
to get into the psychology of it and I
think it's because you're constantly
being tested you're constantly having
this little challenge of almost trying
to one-up yourself in a way there are
some times when it's like okay I know I
can build a bridge over this but you
know what instead I'm gonna try to just
make something crazy ridiculous just to
see if it will work and then sometimes
you have things that you didn't really
intend but hey they work out
the other one is recall and admittedly I
have not used that one as much yet I
think there's a lot of potential for
that one however to me that one is the
most similar to things that I have seen
in games before a lot of us were even
talking about at times it reminds me of
the old Prince of Persia sands of Time
game I mean it's not quite like that it
has more of a focus on rewinding objects
than necessarily oh I fell to my death
now I need to go back so I don't want to
speak as much on that one because I feel
like I've barely just tapped into it at
all yet did I say three things uh that
was all one right there so moving on to
number two of why I think this may win
you over a little bit more if you didn't
love breath of the wild is that the
story is better it it straight up is
better I am more invested in this story
right from the beginning they're doing a
much better job of managing it which is
really difficult to do when you have
this vast open world and you can quite
literally go in any direction and do
just about anything you want there's
this air of mystery right away of the
story of you wanting to find out what's
next what exactly is happening to Zelda
don't worry I'm not going to spoil
anything here for you if there's a point
you're gonna reach in the game where you
have these sort of not really main
missions but they slowly start to peel
back the layers of the story even more
and it's been a long time since I played
breath of the wild but I will say that
as a whole this feels more like the
whole world everybody in Hyrule is aware
of what's going on there's a new
mechanic let's just say of news getting
around the world in this game so it at
least has a story reason for making
sense of why all these people are going
to be talking about this event that
happened and why we can't find Zelda and
then third we have the open world itself
which maybe I get some pushback from
people who really love breath of the
Wild on this but personally I don't
remember breath of the wild being this
engaging fun enticing enticing might be
a good word I've already seen so many
people talking about the fact that
you'll set a marker on your map and it
may be very close to you but you can
guarantee that on the way to that marker
you're gonna find about five other
things that will draw your attention
away now if all of these little extra
things though weren't really drawing you
in and they didn't seem worthwhile then
yeah it would get annoying after a while
but so far all of these little extra
side things that keep drawing me in
every time I go through and pursue it I
find oh that was worth my time I enjoyed
that I either got something cool from it
or had an awesome new experience learned
something new about the story that I
didn't know every single time you're
getting a little reward and I don't even
mean an in-game reward sometimes it's
that but not always the way that this
world is structured and put together is
just Immaculate and I'm only scratching
the surface I mean I'm still very early
into the game if you want to actually
see me play through it I have uploaded
part one over on our let's play Channel
you can check that out on the right side
of your screen now as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon